[Music]
fracking for gas on uk soon
a divisive subject fraught with
uncertainty i think we could have
another girl but i don't know who will
so it's a guessing game at the moment
it's very much a guessing game
the american style shale gas revolution
never quite materialized over here and
three years ago amid earthquakes and
opposition drilling was banned we are
not able to get it out of the ground in
a way that is safe in a way that is not
hugely disruptive
but russia's invasion of ukraine is
driving an energy crisis
uk gas prices are astronomically high
and energy security is top of the agenda
we will be using gas for a very long
time yet if we have it here under our
feet then for heaven's sake let's use
that
so now the government is thinking again
on fracking
is it worth the risk or is it a dead end
it's the wrong place
the wrong time and it's the wrong
direction
it's ridiculous
so you can see the flare stack
and the and the exterior friends and the
site itself yeah yeah it's just there
when it was flaring you could actually
see
the
the glow and the the smoke coming out of
the flask could you yeah yeah when they
were drilling we could hear the drilling
and that was like a constant wine
chris and susan holliday live in little
pompton village in lancashire their
house is nearly opposite what was the
preston new road drill site an
exploratory fracking project run by a
company called quadrilla to test the
flow of the shale gas deep underground
here up to the surface
but fracking can cause seismic activity
and in 2019 that's just what happened an
earthquake measuring 2.9 on the richter
scale we were in the kitchen and when it
happened we you know literally the
crockery in the cupboards was rattling
windows were shaking
i was cleaning and there was a bang it's
very unsettling it's very unnerving
and you're very very concerning that you
you're living with this and in our case
just 500 or so meters away from our
homes do we want to have any fracking
anywhere
[Applause]
for the many who had protested against
the drilling that earthquake was proof
of a potentially dangerous industry
gaining a foothold in the uk
the government already spooked by a
series of smaller tremors in previous
months and years suspended fracking
indefinitely
it felt like a victory to barbara
richardson she'd spent years as a member
of a group called the nana's even
attracting celebrity support from the
likes of actor emma thompson
it was hard because at first people
wouldn't listen to us you know people
thought
loads of activity you know and we were
called all sorts green blobs protested
you know greeting all the insults that
people we're just normal people who saw
the damage that this industry would do
and felt we had to challenge that
what got you going
the injustice of it really at the end of
the day the fact that
the industry want to force this on
communities and it's not right
but a lot has changed from a few years
ago when the decision was made to stop
exploring for shale gas
now there's an energy crisis the prices
consumers are paying are soaring and the
government wants us to increase our
energy security and so despite all the
disruption and community opposition to
sites like this that includes asking
scientists to take another look at
fracking
so this is a drift mine professor peter
styles is one of the country's leading
geologists
he specializes in monitoring seismic
activity and has advised the government
on fracking and when work should be
stopped wow
coal was removed above us in an old mine
near stokon trent he explains why the
legacy of coal
makes drilling for gas even deeper
underground a real challenge
why does the existence of coal mines
matter to fracking any fractures which
we see here
will also be present
in the shale beneath
and in lots of parts of the uk
the coals above that shell have been
worked if you disturb the berlin shale
how are you going to affect
all of the coal mines which lie above
them
and in parts of yorkshire and lancashire
probably about 50 percent of the area
which is occupied by the bull and chill
has coal mines above it
and there's no way of avoiding the coal
mines if you're going to frack
meaningfully it's quite difficult the
geology of the uk is extremely complex
despite these concerns
he thinks the government may have been
too cautious when it stopped the
fracking industry in its tracks three
years ago an earthquake between one and
two on the richter scale is there a real
life equivalent that people could
imagine your windows rattle right it
it's not there's no there's it's not a
damaging event the issue was um public
public dis
disquiet with the effect of having
experienced an earthquake
that was created by an activity that
they were not used to
if you go to japan nobody nobody gets
out of bed for a magnitude 2 earthquake
but that's part of their environment
it's not part of ours the government's
ordered a review into fracking
three years after they essentially
stopped it is that a reasonable thing to
do in your view i think it is yes
it may not it may not work out that it's
a it's a plausible source of energy but
um
we have a lot more data we can look
elsewhere i think we should we should
try to understand it i think we could
have another go but i don't know if we
will
we're at mantor in derbyshire
and this is carboniferous rock
it was laid down about 300 million years
ago petrophysicist paul glover takes us
to see a rare example of exposed shale
to explain what having another go would
actually involve you drill down to the
the level you want to drill down to and
then you add into the well at high
pressures a fluid that is mixed with
particles
the raising the pressure on the fluid is
what fractures the rock at depth the
particles stay behind
and
jack the the fracture open
and then gas can flow around those
particles through the fractures and out
to the surface
it's that process that can cause tremors
and earthquakes
if fracking were to restart the majority
of activity would happen in the north of
england home to what's known as the
bowland shale formation
it covers a huge swathe of ground from
coast to coast from the atlantic coast
all the way over to the north sea from
northern derbyshire here
right up to northumberland at about a
thousand meters depth so very deep
underground very deep in the ground and
spread over a vast area
but there the certainty ends
everyone agrees that the bowline shale
formation is huge
what's much less clear is how much gas
is actually down there the quality of
that gas and whether or not it can even
be extracted and it's going to be really
hard to answer those questions until
drilling gets underway
and that say campaigners would be a
disaster for climate change at the very
moment we should be accelerating
investment in clean energy
but cuadrilla ceo francis egan points
out that even the most ambitious climate
targets include using gas for decades to
come the shale gas industry in the u and
the uk has been frankly demonized we
have complied with every regulation we
have followed government policy we are
trying to extract a product that
everybody in this country everybody
virtually uses the claims that it's
unsafe if that's unsafe then
construction is unsafe mining is unsafe
and geothermal is certainly unsafe
so either one rule applies to all of
them the same rules or if the government
wants to shut it down on the ground it's
unsafe it better shut down the
construction industry in the country
what constitutes safe
is far from the only area of
disagreement
above all fracking has become a deeply
political issue not just between the
parties but within the conservatives too
and at the heart of the argument is a
calculation
is it worth the risk
you know coachella cannot operate within
the traffic light system mark menzies
whose lancashire constituency filed for
the brunt of the first attempts at
drilling has had enough of the fracking
industry i'm afraid they've lost their
license to operate as far as i'm
concerned you don't trust them
i certainly don't trust them no the
government would be absolutely you know
wrong-headed to think that press new
roads could be you know given the green
light again two national moratoriums
speak volumes
intertwined with the politics is the
issue of cost energy economist dieter
helm warns that unlike america and its
booming shale gas industry fracking here
doesn't really add up if you go to the
united states you've got wide open
planes
very low population densities uniform
rock structures so
no real problem here in the uk
look at the geography you know look down
at how densely populated this country is
look at the complexity of the geology
think about what's involved in getting
the stuff out and getting it to market
it's whether it's economic sensible and
in a complex
situation like the uk whether it makes
local environmental sense too and my
guess is the answer is probably not
but many disagree
we're going to need oil and gas for the
next 20 to 30 years at least and
possibly longer the only question then
is are we going to be getting from under
our own feet which is what fracking is
all about or are we going to be getting
it from abroad importing it from places
like qatar
saudi arabia and heaven forbid russia
if we're doing that what's happening is
that we are shipping away
all the opportunity that comes from the
oil and gas industry to other places and
paying their taxes yeah
craig mckinley is chair of the net zero
scrutiny group a collection of
conservative mps pushing back against
the government's climate targets with
shale gas extraction would become a lot
of investment a lot of jobs nice lot of
tax revenue for the treasury we need
that
won't be any government money this will
be private money private businesses
you know big corporates if it works it
works good luck to them if it doesn't
they've made an investment that that's
failed i don't see any downside for the
british public only an upside if it
works
as the pressure from backbenchers builds
the government says it wants to be led
by the science on fracking and won't
lift the moratorium unless it is shown
to be safe sustainable and of minimal
disturbance to those living nearby
as the british geological survey
finalizes its review on these issues the
government will have to decide on
whether to give an industry with a
controversial history and an uncertain
future another chance
[Applause]
hannah thomas peter sky news
[Applause]